This episode has been supported by Lambda
Labs.
Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In our earlier paper, Gaussian Material Synthesis,
we made a neural renderer, and what this neural
renderer was able to do is reproduce the results
of a light transport simulation within 4 to
6 milliseconds in a way that is almost pixel
perfect.
It took a fixed camera and scene, and we were
able to come up with a ton of different materials,
and it was always able to guess what the output
would look like if we changed the physical
properties of a material.
This is a perfect setup for material synthesis
where these restrictions are not too limiting.
Trying to perform high-quality neural rendering
has been a really important research problem
lately, and everyone is asking the question,
can we do more with this?
Can we move around with the camera and have
a neural network predict what the scene would
look like?
Can we do this with animations?
Well, have a look at this new paper which
is a collaboration between researchers at
the Technical University of Munich and Stanford
University, where all we need is some video
footage of a person or object.
It takes a close look at this kind of information,
and can offer three killer applications.
One, it can synthesize the object from new
viewpoints.
Two, it can create a video of this scene and
imagine what it would look like if we reorganized
it, or can even add more objects to it.
And three, perhaps everyone’s favorite,
performing facial reenactment from a source
to a target actor.
As with many other methods, these neural textures
are stored on top of the 3D objects, however,
a more detailed, high-dimensional description
is also stored and learned by this algorithm,
which enables it to have a deeper understanding
of intricate light transport effects create
these new views.
For instance, it is particularly good at reproducing
specular highlights, which typically change
rapidly as we change our viewpoint for the
object.
One of the main challenges was building a
learning algorithm that can deal with this
kind of complexity.
The synthesis of mouth movements and teeth
was always the achilles heel of these methods,
so have a look at how well this one does with
it!
You can also see with the comparisons here
that in general, this new technique smokes
the competition.
So how much training data do we need to achieve
this?
I would imagine that this would take hours
and hours of video footage, right?
No, not at all.
This is what the results look like as a function
of the amount of training data.
On the left, you see that is already kinda
works with 125 images, but contains artifacts,
but if we can supply a 1000 images, we’re
good.
Note that a 1000 images sounds like a lot,
but it really isn’t, it’s just half a
minute worth of video.
How crazy is that?
Some limitations still apply, you see one
failure case right here, and the neural network
typically needs to be retrained if we wish
to use it on new objects, but this work finally
generalizes to multiple viewpoints, animation,
scene editing, lots of different materials
and geometries, and I can only imagine what
we’ll get two more papers down the line.
Respect to Justus for accomplishing this,
and in general, make sure to have a look at
Matthias Niessner’s lab, who just got tenured
as a full professor and he’s only 32 years
old.
Congratulations!
If you have AI-related ideas, and you would
like to try them, but not do it in the cloud
because you wish to own your own hardware,
look no further than Lambda Labs.
Lambda Labs offers sleek, beautifully designed
laptops, workstations and servers that come
pre-installed with every major learning framework
and updates them for you, taking care of all
the dependencies.
Look at those beautiful and powerful machines!
This way, you can spend more of your time
with your ideas, and don’t have to deal
with all the software maintenance work.
They have an amazing roster of customers that
include Apple, Microsoft, Amazon, MIT and
more.
These folks really know what they are doing.
Make sure to go to lambdalabs.com/papers or
click their link in the video description
and look around, and if you have any questions,
you can even even call them for advice.
Big thanks to Lambda Labs for supporting this
video and helping us make better videos for
you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!